why do we need to change the narrative
around fathers
we need to change the narrative about
fathers partly because the one we have
at the moment is a complete fiction
which is kind of made up from many myths
and stories we've been told in our
culture over the years about the role of
fathers about their importance to their
children about how they become fathers
how they learn the knowledge to become
fathers and actually all of this is
based upon absolutely zero academic
research absolutely no observational
research at all it's just stories that
we've told each other anecdotes and
because of that the myths we've built up
around fathers are just out there myths
they're not actually true and they are
very damaging to fathers they're
damaging to men and they're also
damaging to their families
um so the work that I do and those are
my colleagues around the world we do it
because we actually want the facts to be
out there we want the stories we tell
about fathers to actually be accurate
which myths do you wish that you could
put into the ground and fully bury about
dads
uh the first one I'll bury is that
fathers men are not instinctive parents
so we have this story and I hear it a
lot still from the dads that I study
when before they have children which is
that like mum is an instinctive parents
she's somehow like magically able to do
this whereas dads have to learn and
because of that they tend to seem what
mum does as a gold standard of parenting
and whatever they do as a secondary bit
of a failure and actually it's not true
and we'll probably go into that a little
bit later but we've we've discovered
that men are as biologically primed to
parent as women are which as an
evolutionary Anthropologist makes
perfect sense to me but that's probably
one of the biggest ones because it
really undermines a man's confidence
that he feels that actually if he just
goes with what his gut is telling him
he will be okay he really a lot of them
lack a lot of confidence and they do
very much belittle themselves in
relation for example to what mom is
doing
yeah it's
there is a demonization of fatherhood
and I want to get into this later as
well but I wonder how much of it
is a COPE in response to single-parent
households and just trying to not make
children who grow up in single-parent
households feel like they're falling
behind because if we minimize the impact
that fathers have on children's rearing
then the people who do grow up with just
mum don't feel like they're missing out
on as much and this is a trend that we
see you know uh it's the tyranny of the
minority is somehow sometimes how it's
categorized but yeah it's so so
fascinating one of the other things uh
William Castello who's one of David
buss's students out here told me a story
that you taught him about how fathers
saved the human race for extinction
because babies heads got too big yeah
okay so what happened so our brains are
six times bigger than they should be for
an animal of our of our size of our body
weight and we're also bipedal so we have
this massive problem with our anatomy
about 1.8 million years ago to start
with where our hips had narrowed because
our we've gone bipedal so the birth
canal got narrower but we had this big
increase in the size of our brains for
example compared to chimps and we got to
this point about 1.8 million years ago
where the head would no longer fit
through the pelvis at full term
so we started having to birth our babies
very preterm basically we should be
pregnant for much much longer than we
are uh and that meant you have this
helpless baby and Mum wasn't able to do
that entirely on her own
um particularly if she had like Toddlers
and everybody else around her initially
women helped each other with kin
and that was fine for about just over a
million years and then about half a
million years ago our brains took a
massive leap again and suddenly just
relying on your sisters your grandmother
your mom whoever it might be wasn't
enough
and actually the race our species was
threatened with extinction because these
babies were not surviving
and so what happened whoops what
happened next was that the the next
genetically related person had to step
in and that was Dad now this was a big
thing for mammals for a mammal because
only five percent of mammals actually
have investing fathers so we're really
rare and we're actually the only ape
that does it so this was a big big
evolutionary step for a mammal to take
for Dad to stick around but if Dad
hadn't stuck around the species I would
argue would have died out because there
are all these babies and none of them
were surviving and none of those genes
were carrying on German generation so we
would have hit a really difficult
demographic problem
lots of interesting things there first
off
if it wasn't for the width of women's
hips how long do you think they would
gestate for
we don't really know
probably getting to maybe
pushing towards elephantine levels so at
least 18 months yeah
if not slightly longer because you've
got a big brain to grow in there and
that takes a lot of energy and it takes
a lot of time
is
it's it's not quite an arms race but it
is an evolutionary trade-off between how
much mum needs to walk and uh how long
the child needs to gestate for yes yes
and the way we dealt with that and the
way we dealt with this demographic
nightmare is we birthed our babies
earlier and earlier and earlier and
that's why when you look at a chimp baby
it's like bounding around the trees
after a week and look at a human baby
and oh my God you've got years before
it's going to be doing that it's just a
puddle for the next two years yeah
exactly if any you know fennel's looked
after newborn baby you know how
unbelievably helpless they are and that
was the trade-off but that meant that in
the classic classic statement it then
started to take a village to raise the
child because you suddenly had this kid
who was helpless but was growing this
enormous brain that was going to need
loads and loads of support
and MPI male parental investment uh just
to like really really drive this home
how rare this is 95 of all mammal
species have zero male parental
investment and none of the other ape
family do like we are outlier yeah
and the reason for that and and that's
why we then go on to this argument of
how important fathers are because if
fathers hadn't been important and if
they weren't still important they just
wouldn't have evolved they just would
not have evolved because evolution
it hates what we call redundancy so what
it what it doesn't do is it doesn't
invent
or cause to evolve two roles which are
identical or near each other unless
they're really needed so it wouldn't
have caused a human father to evolve
unless he was absolutely critical for
the survival of the species it just
doesn't work like that
go back uh 750 000 years ago what would
the typical father have done
the typical of the 750 000 years ago
would have probably acted very much like
a chimp father
um I would probably have probably
side several children with several
different females because reproductive
success in terms of evolution the only
thing that's important is reproductive
success how many kids are you having are
they surviving are they themselves
reproducing okay so before we had
investing files before Dad had to do
that he would have been spreading his
seat because that would have increased
the likelihood of reproductive success
but we got to this Tipping Point where
he was doing that and oh my God none of
them were surviving
okay so actually your reproductive
success is pretty much zero and so
Evolution will have selected for those
men who stuck around and actually
started investing but the but the
problem is you get to the point where a
man you could say well he could just
carry on you know starring several
children with several different women
but the problem you have is that first
of all
he wants paternity certainty so if he's
doing that that means all the other that
means the women who he is mating with
are also mating with other men
and then you've got this conundrum of oh
my God I I'm now possibly investing in
someone else's child and I don't really
want to do that so the way I deal with
this is I do a thing called mate
guarding which a lot of uh primates who
do couple up do and I'm going to stick
by the female side but if you stick by
the female side you're not mating with
everyone else and you slowly move into
this thing where we have for a greater
or less a period of time what we call
parental monogamy and that the father
sticks with the woman
only mates with that woman and helps to
raise the children because that's the
only way his genes are going to survive
so I got sent something by Mac and
Murphy earlier on uh right this is re
this is really interesting so this is a
pushback against
um Alpha Tate uh alpha male sort of
hyper Andrew Tate approach as being
what's classed as reproductive success
and a tweet from him says I've always
been skeptical of sexual partner count
as a measure of male reproductive
success in our species concealed
ovulation and contraception make it
rather unlikely that a man will produce
children through anything other than
long-term committed relationships and it
got me thinking about how this is
reflected ancestrally as well that you
know spreading your seed around even the
most Alpha of alpha males it doesn't
track using wolves or chimp tribes or
silverback gorillas as the model for us
because the children come out in a very
different sort of way and as you
identified and anyone that's read the
April understood the universe knows
humans are grandchild children
optimizing machines that's the thing
that needs to happen once you get to the
stage of grandchildren sweet like our
hands are off the wheel so to speak but
yeah I think it's a really nice reframe
um and it also maybe
explains I don't know how long 500 000
years is
evolutionarily pretty long time but
I think a lot of men
um feel in them a a little conflict that
you know they want Dad but they want
Chad in their own lives they want to
kind of and there is a battle that I see
amongst my friends I'm 35 and I'm seeing
these uh former degenerates uh start to
calm down a little bit and but they
still have this sort of Vestige of what
they used to be but they have this
desire for what they want to become and
I almost see perhaps the 750 000 year
ago version of them battling with the
250 000 year old version of them and I I
do think you know it's who's going to
give men
um sympathy for oh poor poor party boys
like starting to settle down like you
know the adult infant the juvenile that
he really needs to grow up about yo I'm
I'm on board like a I've been around
enough of these these are my friends but
I do think that it's interesting to see
the knobs and the the dials start to get
tweaked a little bit you know we talk a
lot about the the change for women
they've hit and uncharitably hit the
wall or largely just I realize that this
is now the time for me to settle down
but no one really ever talks about the
equivalent with men and I do think that
I see it in my friends it's like
I need to grow up I need to stop being
such an adult infant yeah absolutely and
and in fact I do have a colleague in uh
in Finland who does study male baby lust
and it's something that again we don't
we don't talk about we talk about
ticking clocks for women and the fact
that they get this sudden insatiable
desire to have children but men have it
too and it's partly because of as you go
as you age your testosterone naturally
declines anyway
um and so test what testosterone is
really really good at in high volumes is
helping you find a mate it's really good
at focusing your attention on that scene
it's really good at giving you all those
features which women find attractive it
makes you very driven about finding a
mate but as your age actually it
declines and it's a natural
um Decline and you start to focus more
upon having a family the other great
thing about it which is the fascinating
thing about testosterone is when you do
become a father for the first time it
drops significantly like really
significantly up to a third
and it will never return to the
pre-birth level as long as you remain in
contact with your child so testosterone
is a very powerful hormone but I think
it's until very recently we didn't
realize how important it was in shaping
fatherhood shaping human fatherhood
yeah so there's an interesting parallel
I think going on here that
what was needed ancestrally was uh
resources and protection primarily I'm
going to guess from a father right like
if you're spending 20 hours a day with
an infant in your arms it's hard to go
picking berries or taking down a
wildebeest similarly you are physically
more frail and the child is unbelievably
frail therefore you need someone to play
uh The Bodyguard hypothesis I think
you're uh ex-boss told me on this
podcast Robin Dunbar so I think that
there is um an equivalent change that's
happened culturally
socioeconomically in the modern world
which almost reverses this so women
finally have access uh financially uh
and educationally to not be dependent on
their partners and
emotionally there is a push to almost
reprogram some of the maternal instincts
and some of the pair bonding instincts
that women have you know there was a
famous article in the New York Times
last year by Chelsea conoboy that said
maternal instinct is a myth that men
created to keep women down
um and I think what this has created is
that an assumption women don't need men
financially women don't need men
emotionally so women don't need men
parentally either
that's the stage that we are at least in
some corners of uneducated popular
culture getting to yeah
and our dispensable I would never
reading something about the Y chromosome
and the Y chromosome has does have very
little of any use on it in terms of
genes
and so this argument the one day it'll
die out and actually we won't need any
men and what that really misses is
actually fathers aren't really there for
mothers fathers are there for their
children
so whether or not as a woman
you feel that you need that that that
partner in your life
and I will get into the single parent
thing in a minute what is very clear
from the data that we've collected and
colleagues around the world in the last
15 years is that your children do need
you
so actually it's not about as a woman
I've got my own money I can protect
myself you know it's actually but your
kid needs the input from that father
because actually what fathers bring to
their children is very different from
what mothers do and when I started 15
years ago the Mantra was fathers had no
role in child development because
mothers were the environment of raising
that child mostly she was the major
input into that child's life and
therefore you didn't need Dad around
really and we have found again not
surprising from an evolutionary point of
view that fathers actually have a very
separate unique and important input into
their children's development and if you
don't have that then first of all it has
to be found from somewhere else
so actually the argument from feminists
or women or whatever it should be
shouldn't be I don't need this man the
question should be yes but does your
child need this man
because actually that's what he's there
for
um so maybe you don't want to partner in
your life okay fine co-parent
you know okay you can live separately
this is fine you don't have to be
romantically involved you don't have to
have any financial aid you don't need to
ask him for any protection
but what about the kid
just fundamentally what about the kid
and I think that's that's the argument
yeah a lot of men and dads are feeling
quite Surplus to requirements now I
think um you know we had this as you
identified uh
bit of uncertainty around fathers I
think I had this really
um very formative conversation in a
group
a couple of months ago uh just before we
I found out that I was going to have a
chat with you and it was so timely
because I'm thinking about this and the
role of dads and so on and so forth and
um it was a mastermind filled with a
couple of billionaires and a bunch of
millionaires so these people monetarily
in terms of resources are very very
successful
and they said look let's just do a round
table we've all eaten dinner does
anybody have any challenges that they're
facing uh personally or professionally
throw them out into the group and I
think there was one round One Sweep that
went around and on the second one this
guy said my wife is six months pregnant
seven months pregnant uh all that she's
talking about is the baby and I don't
feel anything and I feel ashamed at the
fact that I'm not like when's this
Cascade of hormones going to come is it
going to come when the baby arrives what
if it doesn't what if I'm not meant to
be a dad you know I I want kids and I
can't wait to have kids but I I don't
feel anything and I'm scared I'm scared
of telling her maybe she's going to
think I'm less of a man I'm not going to
be a good father maybe she's going to
want to leave me
um as there was just
like pouring out of this guy
self-doubt and and and concern and shame
and guilt and Terror uh and I I really
it really touched me you know this guy
opened up and sat right across with
another guy equally successful with
three kids uh and he said same for me
same for me just
hold on it will come it's gonna take
longer
um but in the the point being you know
when we're talking about men and Dad's
feeling Surplus to requirements there is
a
the it's a very vicious sort of
double-ended sword that's happening here
where culture is maybe feeding an
increasing narrative that women can
survive without dads and Dad's a surplus
requirement and we don't want to make
the single parent household people feel
uncomfortable and what that does is it
slots almost perfectly into these fears
that fathers innately have so you have
this almost sort of um extrinsic and
intrinsic
narrative being woven together that
certainly to the guy that was sat next
to me it it played right into the fears
that he already had and it didn't make
him feel like he was any more secure
yeah absolutely and that's why in a way
I do the work I do and I publish the
work I do in a helpful format so that's
why I wrote my book and that's why we
have to get this information out there
about dads Because what he was feeling
is completely and utterly normal I can
think of only maybe
three or four men that I've studied who
haven't had that concern and I've
studied many many men in this process
and
and the other guy at the table was right
it will come but we don't tell men that
you know we hear this thing of oh the
baby will come out and you'll feel
amazing you're feeling dated and it'll
be amazing and you'll immediately love
them
probably not and actually quite a lot of
women don't feel like either let you
into a little secret but
um but it's because and we can explain
that we can explain that Mum when she's
pregnant is there's raging hormones
everywhere when she gives birth she's
got a massive flood of hormones which
help her give birth actually but as a
side effect our amazing bonding hormones
so we've got oxytocin we've got dopamine
we've got beta endorphin in that
accelerating the bond she's going to
build with that baby and that's done
partly because babies are tough and you
don't want her to leave it on the
hillside so okay let's give her some
really good you know chemicals side
effects and she will dads can only build
their bond because they don't go through
that physiological process they don't
breastfeed for example they have to
build their bond through interaction
okay so for example the drop in
testosterone doesn't occur until the
baby is born
so that's first of all a big tough thing
so you're not getting this drop in
testosterone which makes you more
motivated to care for the baby and also
releases more of an effect from your
bonding hormones high testosterone
blocks the effects of bonding hormones
okay so if you drop the you get much
more of an effect of oxytocin and
dopamine and things like that so he's
not getting that Head Start during
pregnancy he has to wait for the baby to
be born then you get this baby who's
born if your partner is breastfeeding
then basically in those first few weeks
there's very little weigh-in because
she's breastfeeding the babies either
asleep or it's crying or whatever it
might be and it's very latched on to Mom
and that's a really tough period I've
had dads who very much that has driven
them to postnatal depression
okay you get postnatal depression as
well
ten percent
talk about and highlight for men so what
I always say to men is I explained to
them physiologically what's happening I
say to them you build your boundary
interaction and those first week's
baby's not doing anything so that's
really hard if you can find a way in
so maybe your thing is baby massage
before bed maybe your thing is giving it
a bath maybe your thing is reading a
story even if it doesn't understand you
it still works
um find your thing and it's your thing
nobody else's thing okay and try and do
it every day but until your baby starts
to interact with you until they start
smiling and babbling and laughing and
looking pleased to see you and then it's
six months they start playing with you
and then you can do Rough and Tumble
play and all these wonderful things
until that time it's going to be tough
but it will come
but we don't tell dads that so they they
sit there thinking either baby doesn't
like me or oh my God I'm not feeling
anything for this baby or and or you
know mum's really good at this why am I
so awful at this how come she's got a
bond how come she knows what's going on
I don't know what's going on so they
build this massive massive pressure and
actually we just need to tell them we
just need to say this is normal and the
fact that you were talking at a man's
group that's brilliant you know we have
in the past set up
antenatal groups Just For Men
and they are amazingly powerful
anti-natal groups yes so so prenatal
groups before the baby is born so in the
UK you know you go to those and you go
with your partner and mum's there and
very little is focused on Dad and dads
tend to not voice their fears in those
environments because they are there
there as like the supporter and The Rock
and they're never they're not going to
say anything mum's going through she's
the one yeah and they're all it's all
about sporting mum what can you do to
support mom
um but actually if you do a man's group
and particularly if you bring in men
like what happened on your evening where
there's a dad there who goes it's okay
they open up amazingly and they will
tell you all their fears and all this
and then having some experienced dads
there is really powerful because they
will turn around and go that happened to
me but I can assure you it's all fine
and they can ask all the silly questions
that they think are silly and they're
not going to ask in front of a load of
women and also most antenatal teachers
are women and it's just a really
powerful thing to do but we have to
prepare these fathers you're like saying
to them you do all this preparation for
a mom and you read all these books and
they say how to support mom and how to
do this and that's really important I
get that
but there's very little out there that
actually says and what about Dad
because he is actually going through a
profound
emotional biological physiological
change as well
it's just not quite as obvious because
it's not a big bump you know but
actually his brain is changing just as
much as hers we know that now from scans
you know we can see the change in a
man's brain when he becomes a father
but we just need to share the knowledge
I think and that's why it's very
important to me to do a lot of talks to
do a lot of podcasts to write the life
of dad because I want and that's written
for fathers because I wanted them to
have a book that wasn't about supporting
mum that wasn't about what's happening
to mum there was about what's happening
to them
because I think that's really important
you've mentioned about this adjustment
in androgens so testosterone drops it
actually drops a little I think when you
get into a committed relationship and
then it does a little and then it's true
again yeah yeah dramatic
what's going on with
gray matter what's happening to our
brain okay so what we see in the brains
is we see two key changes in the brain
which we see and they're identical in
women and we see first of all we see
changes in the very core of the brain um
particularly in the limber care of the
brain the amygdala uh and the
hypothalamus which are related to risk
detection
which is understandable so as a parent
you need to be very good at risk
detection you need to look out for those
for those risks to your baby second
really big ones are in the outer areas
of the brain so we see the areas related
to empathy increase in size which again
is obvious you need to be very good at
reading your child's emotional needs
what their emotional state is what
they're going to need and particularly
when all you've got is somebody
screaming at you you need to be very
good at that the other thing is all
those really good parenting skills like
attention and planning and problem
solving and organizing so those areas of
the brain associated with that some of
them related to Executive function they
also increase in size
so you see all these areas becoming
primed so that you are as good at this
as you possibly can be and we see that
happening in men and in women
I wonder if
uh the hardcore productivity peddled
corner of the internet gets a hold of
this conversation and finds out that
their executive function can be
increased by having kids they might
still having children everyone's having
children yeah having children is a
productivity hack no they'll say look
let me think about how much I'm going to
be able to parallel process my Google
Calendar is going to be completely put
together
um yeah but anyway yeah but true yeah
it's the Sleep offset made derogate that
talk to me about
um this risk detection and stuff and
fear stuff because there's these videos
on the Internet it's um uh dad's it's
like Dad's doing unbelievable things the
child's about on the corner of
the couch and falls off and this father
gets like some Odell Beckham Jr reverse
Crow grip thing or like they pluck some
plucks them before a random tractor
accident occurs or whatever you know
like so there's there's this increase in
that but does this mean that parents
specifically dads but also mothers is
there Baseline anxiety
um is that raised does this bleed across
into the rest of their life too do they
have a sense of fear anxiety stress
whatever occurring as well we do tend to
it's partly it's quite a complex
multi-factorial thing you do see an
increase increasing cortisol in young
parents obviously
um it is a very stressful thing to do
not only with a lack of sleep but also
with the sheer amount of learning you
need to do and the fact that yes you
have to you have to have this heightened
wrist section we do find that men and
it's probably to do with the drop in
testosterone definitely become more
emotional in situations which they feel
relate to them so I always get my dad
saying oh my God I now can't watch
charity appeals on the Telly you know
without crying
it's emotional in a sad Direction it's
not like they get more aggressive
emotional no no they tend not to
actually that's probably because there's
a drop in testosterone so we don't see
in some male other animals who don't
tend to do the caring side but tend to
do for example defense of the nest
we will see more aggressive behavior
that tends to be caused by the increase
in a hormone called vasopressin which
actually isn't terribly important in
humans men have kind of replaced that
with oxytocin so we don't tend to see
increases in aggression but we do tend
to see increases in in stress response
and we see increases in yeah vigilance
basically just sheer vigilance
yeah that's very interesting okay so
let's roll the clock forward this
imaginary father and his imaginary sleep
deprivation has got to maybe three to
six months in and the baby's a little
bit less of a puddle on the floor I've
heard this story of you know it's very
important for the child to lie on the
father's chest skin to skin contact how
much of this is Bro Science and how much
of this is legit
absolutely illegit
if there's one thing I will tell a
father after birth is put that baby on
your chest
um Stell here even though we've spent
years trying to um educate the medical
establishment we still find that fathers
aren't offered it as routine which is
ludicrous
um and we still have to say to them you
have to be assertive enough to ask for
it and say please give me the baby I
want to put the baby on my chest the
reason for that is human babies are
sensory beings like a lot of little baby
mammals they do everything their senses
are very heightened one of the senses
that's not heightened is vision
but they are amazing at smelling they're
amazing at feeling and touch so if you
put them on your chest as a father what
happens is they first of all they smell
you and they start to smell who you are
because they can't really see you
secondly a wonderful thing called by
behavioral synchrony happens so when you
put a baby on your chest
base their physiology starts to go into
time with your physiology so they'll
come to the same temperature as you
their heart rate will come to the same
heart rate as you their but their blood
pressure will come to same blood
pressure as you okay also touch is the
key release of bonding hormones
it you know oxytocin dopamine b-trend
orphan if you want to release those the
best thing you can do is use Touch
um so skin to skin contact after birth
skin is in contact at any point during
the baby's life is really really
critical for fathers so it's something
that's routinely given to women
but not to men and actually in a way
arguably it's more critical for men
because mum's got that little bit of
head start with her bonding hormones
having gone through childbirth
um but it's really critical as the first
interaction between a father and child I
think Robin taught me about the
release of bonding hormones when
finger over skin movement is kept at two
centimeters per second or less yeah
there's a particular yeah that's true
there's a particular Rhythm and it's why
we find some touch or some stroking
irritating
and some stroking really lovely and I
suppose you know you might if we you
know you have a partner who's strikes
and sometimes you're like no that's
really and it's usually because it's at
the wrong frequency
we have these special special hairs and
special nerve cells in our skin and it's
just a very particular strength right
apparently that was if you run that back
and you look at the primatology side of
it it's a pace at which it would be
quick enough to be able to find and
groom fur
but if it was any quicker than that
you're not going through and actually
being able to pick out whatever the
things yeah okay so
we've spoken about kind of some of the
challenges that both dads and mums face
what is the difference in the roles that
mums and dads are supposed to play like
why are they here when it comes to the
raising of children okay so we have to
this this is where it can all get
horribly political and I can be
misquated horribly and picked up by both
sides of the argument
from an evolutionary point of view as I
mentioned earlier Evolution hates
redundancy so it will not cause two
roles like parenting roles to be exactly
identical if they're not if that's not
required
um so what's happened in human evolution
is that there are some things that both
parents do
so both parents are care both parents
are highly empathetic if you look at the
brain activity in the brains of mothers
and fathers when they're interacting
with their children we see equal we see
synchrony in empathetic areas of the
brain we see synchrony in you know the
caretaking areas of the brain
but beyond that there are some really
distinct differences and they seem to
relate partly to The evolutionary age
of the two roles
and partly to the fact that mum's role
is quite biologically constrained
um partly by childbirth partly by
breastfeeding particularly in the early
stages where Dad's role is much more
flexible so what we have found is that
if we look at Peak activations in the
brain when we're looking at interactions
with Mom Dad and baby the big activation
is in the paternal brain are in the core
of the brain so the limbicare of the
brain the unconscious brain very very
very ancient As Old As Time
um and that's where nurturing is and
attachment is and risk detection is so
there's really fundamental caring things
so you know you look at the tiniest
little Vol or Mouse and it's got the
same thing happening in its brain
dads obviously that bit lights up but
the peak in activation is actually in
the neocortex the oh the newest bit of
the brain which is understandable
because it's an evolutionarily quite
young fatherhood and there we see a lot
of uh activation in the social cognition
areas of the brain so that's at the
front of the brain
um and that's to do with being able to
sort of maneuver your way to the
complexities of social life
and there's lots of different things
involved in that so it might be social
communication
it might be things like empathy it might
be things like what we call sharing
caring and helping
um but it can also be things like
resilience mental resilience
um and so dad's role
I've kind of reduced it in a simple
catchphrase but dad's role is to
scaffold the child's entry into the
world beyond the family
so
what Dad is there to do is once all that
very initial nurturing has happened and
the baby's starting to to grow and maybe
mum has another baby is to take that
child
and this is what would have happened 500
000 years ago take that toddler
and start to prepare them to go beyond
the family so the first thing they might
do is go to preschool and we know from
research that the attachment of Father
builds with their child the sensitivity
of their parenting to that child is the
biggest predictor in how well that child
transitions into preschool so how good
are they how how good are they sharing
caring and helping how good is their
social communication how good is their
emotional inhibition and regulation
those are all driven mostly by the
relationship that child has with their
father
because it seems to me that Dad is the
key to this and what's really
interesting is as an anthropologist I
study fathering around the world so
obviously
how our culture views for this does vary
um and we have certain views in the west
and those aren't necessarily the views
shared around the world
but what we do see is regardless of
whatever culture you're in
every dad is doing that social
scaffolding when you reduce everything
away that's what he's doing so it might
be you know studied a group in Kenya
called the kip sigis who are tea
Planters quite a patriarchal Community
very male driven but Dad will take well
first of all as soon as the child is
able he will take the child into fields
to teach them how to use the crop but
the most important thing he does is he
takes them to the market
and he teaches them how to build the
social network that's going to enable
that kid to negotiate and sell the tea
so he will do that even in the west we
do that you know Dad might be might you
know get the really good um work
experience gig because he's built a
really good Network on the golf course
or at the country club or wherever it
might be and so dads are very
involved in making sure their kid has
the network has the social skill has the
resilience to actually survive in our
world and part of that resilience is
things like taking appropriate risk
helping you know helping them deal with
challenge helping them deal with failure
um and we see that from very early age
that's what Rough and Tumble play does
partly and so Dad is there to make sure
this kid has the skills to survive
outside the family and that seems to be
the key role of fathers
what is the role of challenge that seems
to be one of the key differences that
you found between Mum and Dad yeah the
role for challenge is because you know
we live in a really difficult world
as a as a child and as an adolescent
have to learn to deal with that
challenge navigate that challenge get
over it deal with failure dust yourself
down get yourself back up maybe find a
different way around it or whatever it
might be I think and you need to you
need to be given those challenges in a
way as a child which is
challenging but not too much
and that and that's difficult
um you know some some parents shook away
from that completely and it's the whole
cotton wool ball thing
others might go a little bit too far
um but it's really important your child
confronts Challenge and it seems to me
that Dad is the key one in doing that
and it starts because of rough and
tumble play so rough and tumble play
starts it around
six to nine months it's when you see
fathers and most fathers do this and
most people recognize it you know it's
when you you know um it's quite
rambustious it's quite physical they'll
be wrestling they'll be tickling they'll
be running around they'll be jumping off
stuff they'll be throwing each other
around the room and it's really critical
to Child Development and when dad say to
me what's the one thing I can do with my
child to build our bonds to help my
child I'll say play with them
it is the most critical thing and this
whole fun parent thing kind of annoys me
a little bit because actually when dads
do it they're not I mean it's fun but
they're not doing it because they're the
fun parent they're doing it because it
actually developmentally is critical to
the child because the child starts to
learn about reciprocity and social
relationships play has to be fun for
both people otherwise it's you know it
descends so it's that give and take of
Play It's understanding you know am I
actually pushing the other person too
much that they're not enjoying this
anymore so empathy is involved it's
about physical challenge oh my God this
is quite difficult but I know Samantha
it's about risk how can I assess risk
actually flinging myself off the top of
this climbing frame it might be too much
so and it actually starts to build the
child's ability to see all those things
and that just goes on throughout life so
we know looking at adolescence
that the biggest factor in a child's
mental health when we look at the
parental input is actually the
relationship they have with their dad
is like the superhero of mental
resilience for boys and girls for boys
and actually for girls it's even more
powerful
and we think though it's only really
been studied
in the west though there's been a few
studies in China
um we think that's because in a
patriarchal world if you have a dad
who spends time with you
who inputs into your life who values
your opinions first of all it's amazing
for your self-esteem
uh and it's saying you know you are
valuable what you say is valuable and
I'm going to support you in saying it
and in a patriarchal world that's quite
a powerful message to give a girl but
it's okay for you to voice Who You Are
and I am here and I'm going to support
you in that
um so actually it can be a bigger impact
on girls than on boys
so that's just getting up into
adolescence just to round out that sort
of conversation about play what does
play do for the father or for the bond
with the father beyond the child in
isolation I know risk I know reciprocity
I know empathy yeah okay so it's one of
the key ways that fathers build their
bonders through Play Because as I've
said you have to interact with your
child
um and one of the key ways you can do it
is through reference double play because
because it's
fast and it's breathless and it's
exercise and it's touch and sometimes
it's a little bit of pain it releases a
lot of oxytocin and particularly beta
and dolphin which is your body's
painkiller and is released during
exercise and those are really powerful
bonding chemicals and because it's so
fast and so in a way time efficient it
does it in this souped-up way so you
could give your baby a massage that
would be lovely and they get some
b-trend orphan they get some oxytocin
but if you Rough and Tumble play with
them it's much much more of an impact
much higher levels of those chemicals so
it's actually a really good way of
building a tight Bond pretty quickly
with a child what's really really
interesting is rough and tumble play is
mainly a western phenomenon
we do see it in other cultures
but it's rarer and that is because most
fathers in Western cultures don't have
much time with their children
they are time poor because of the
culture we have and they're the primary
Breadwinner and therefore this is
developed to enable them to very quickly
bond with their children's home
efficiently High Roi uh strategy for
bonding yeah yeah whereas if we go and
look at let's go look at the akka okay
who are in the Congo they are the most
Hands-On fathers in the world they spend
at least about 55 to 60 of their day in
actual physical contact with their
children
they don't really do it but they are
with their children all day they're
carrying them they're singing to them
they're telling them stories they're
going on the on the net hunt with them
they don't need to do it in the same way
and so they don't
I know that it's going to be hard to
make the comparison because the
difference in culture and so on is there
something different about the
upbringing the risk tolerance the
empathy either in childhood adolescence
or adulthood of the children who are
given this more protracted lower
intensity bond with Dad uh from the akka
as opposed to the high peak High Roi
thing I'm wondering if there's something
that the Rough and Tumble play gives or
doesn't give that a flatter longer
equivalent of play per day does no we
don't really see any difference actually
in terms of bonding in terms of
attachment in terms of adjustment of
children
um the only difference actually between
something like the akka and maybe some
Western fall this is the degree to which
they will allow their children to
confirm risk so little lack of baby
little lack of toddlers are walking
around with knives
you know it's it's a hunter-gatherer of
society they don't quite have the same
uh I don't know lack of tolerance for
for severe risk and actually children
learning skills early on so actually
that's really the only difference you
see with them is that they're there you
know lighting fires and carrying knives
and doing all these things at a very
young age which probably most of us was
kind of bought at but they seem to be
fine
roll the clock forward then let's get
into adolescence and the particularly
useful role of dads when we get there
yeah
adolescence is a key time
um and it's a time when we see a lot of
rewiring of the Adolescent brain so when
you go through puberty there's a lot of
dewiring rewiring and it's a difficult
time for children it's a particularly
different time mental health wise
because we're starting to see a change
in the focus of attachment from parents
to peers
and that means that actually your
ability to navigate the social world at
that point is really really critical
and we see a lot of the mental health
issues that young people have manifest
themselves within the social sphere so
things like social anxiety for example
things like body issues they tend to be
within the social sphere caused partly
by the society in which the child lives
and because of that it seems to be that
because Dad is the one that has these
skills to scaffold the child and also
the person who has been like the key
resilience builder in the child that
continues into adolescence but what's
really interesting is Dad doesn't really
have to do anything amazing so you don't
have to spend hours with your adolescent
or you don't have to
um you know spend lots and lots of money
actually what seems to work with
adolescents is just feeling that you as
a father value their company
and you as a father as a busy person
have taken the time to spend time with
them maybe doing a hobby they like or it
can be something as mundane as washing
the car walking the dog making Sunday
lunch just something where the dad has
said I'm going to spend this time with
you
and what's really interesting is is how
children viewed whether or not their
parents value them differs between mums
and dads say do you want to think their
mum values them if their mom remembers
their favorite breakfast cereal or you
know make sure their Sports kit is
packed or all that kind of thing they
value their dads Because
they value they feel they have that
values them because she spends time with
them
and that might be because you know Dad's
time is seen as this very concertina
thing
um so it's about doing those things with
the child it's about having a secure
attachment to the child and secure
attachment starts as soon as birth
begins but if you can maintain that
secure attachment all the way through to
adolescence it's really really powerful
and we know that what you do with your
kid as an adolescent as a father carries
them well into young adulthood so
they've been studies showing that dads
who have good secure attachments who
spend time with their children first of
all those kids have much higher
self-esteem they're much more less
likely to have things like depression or
anxiety they're much less likely to
report loneliness but as a as a young
adult for a start their mental health is
better but also for example just dealing
with things like stressful things in
their daily life they are much more
capable of dealing with those things
yeah I've got it in my head about trying
to fold into the discussion
of
teen girl depression 60 of 12 to 16 year
old U.S females say that they have
regular or persistent feelings of
hopelessness
etc etc etc
I'm trying to
work out or deduct the base rate from
that of fatherless homes I'm trying to
work out you know whether Jonathan
height is correct at folding this at the
feet of smartphones and a hijack of
female comparison during the time that
they switch from parent to peer
Association
and how much of it is a little bit more
fundamental than that and it's absentee
fathers that could be absentee fathers
uh due to it being single parent
households that could be due to the
increase in living costs and the fact
that Dad needs to work more which means
that they're not as involved that could
be
if Jonathan is uh adamant that it needs
to be to do with technology it could be
to do with the distraction or the
increase in distractibility of dad from
screens which means that he's not
spending as much time with kids but yeah
looking at the pathologies and
challenges that young men and young
women are facing as they get into
adolescence and then young adulthood
can you draw lines between fatherless
homes or a lack of male parental input
into raising kids up
do you know what you've mentioned so
many different factors there and they
will all be important because it's a
multi-factorial problem I want to make
two points the first is that we need to
be very careful about what we mean when
we talk about a father okay in the west
we associate the word father with
biological father and so we talk about
father absence because the biological
father is not in the home or not in the
life of the child
if you look in other cultures in the
world
that obsession with biological
fatherhood is a little bit strange
so in some societies the biological
father doesn't really Factor at all
particularly in matriarchal societies uh
in many societies they have what's known
as a social father and that can be a
grandfather and Uncle an elder brother
lots of people so in South Africa for
example it's quite normal within black
communities for the grandfather to raise
the children because the father has to
go away to work and that's perfectly
normal and the grandfather has a special
name for father
um in some societies kids have whole
teams of fathers who will do something
different and that might be the
biological father and a load of social
fathers who knows so I think we need to
be very careful about talking about
absentee fathers because actually if you
look at many children who are in single
parent households with a mother
if you ask them who are the significant
men in your life they will come up with
some
and we assume there is no Father Figure
in their life but that Father Figure
doesn't have to be the dad it could be
the grandparent it could be a teacher it
could be a coach it could be a brother
it could be your mom's best friend
um it doesn't have to be the biological
father it has to be someone who is
willing to and might even not even
consciously know what they are doing
but they are feeding into that child's
development so first of all I would make
that point
um that we are very vast in the west
towards biological fathers and we
needn't be
um secondly it's very multifactorial
um certainly I think I think
part of the reason I support fathers in
relation to moral quality in the home
with things like paternity leave and
things like that is because they are
important to children and they are
important to Child Development and we
find that children who have more input
from their father do tend to be more
resilient and they do tend to be have
more successful outcomes particularly
girls
so you know that is a factor having that
that Father Figure in your life and
that's why we do try and fight here in
the UK for more rights for fathers
um but then again I agree social media
is an issue and I talk about that in a
very different area of my life talking
about the mismatch between uh the speed
of evolution of the human brain and the
speed of our ability to innovate so we
have a very very ancient brain that
can't cope with the way we've innovated
the iPhone for example we are not made
to operate within that environment and
it's a major it handicaps our brain's
ability
uh we don't get all those lovely
positive bonding hormones we don't
we are seeing something that quite often
is lying to us and we're not terribly
good at spotting what's lying to us if
it's not right in front of us so theory
of mind we're not very good at theory of
mind at a distance
so social media certainly has a role I
think but it's not the only role and it
really does depend upon the child so
there's a real interplay between a
child's personality
and social media so you will get a child
you could get one child who was on
social media eight hours a day and would
be completely unaffected by it and then
you'll get another child who is more
vulnerable it's really really
complicated but I think the reason why I
try and unpick the fatherhood bit of it
is because
kids have evolved to have these two
roles in their lives
and the science shows us that the dads
are primed to do this well the science
shows us that the fathers are important
developmentally to their children we
know that where fathers have secure
attachments to their children the
children have better outcomes and we
know that that's good for society
so the reason why I fight for fatherhood
and more equality in the home
uh is because of that and because it is
good for children it's good for fathers
it's good families and it's good for
society it's good for women if you can
get fathers if you can get equal
paternity leave for fathers with
materials women can go back to work
sooner they have less of a career
penalty they're then sharing what we
call the career penalty with the fathers
the gender pay Gap reduces you know so
it's kind of for those of us who
campaign and do the research of us it's
kind of a bit of a no-brainer but
um convincing governments is another
issue yeah why is it the case given that
there are mothers want the best outcomes
for their children
um mothers also want the best outcomes
presumably for themselves
these are facilitated
through making men more integrated
through making them more necessary into
the raising of children
is it just short-sightedness and a lack
of insight into your work that's causing
a kind of anti-dad
surplus of requirements male narrative
at the moment culturally do you think
there are several things our media
culture hasn't changed enough so we
still it's getting better we have less
representations of the completely
useless dad
um or the Surplus died in adverts on
telly in sitcoms but it's still there
it's a very ingrained
a belief Homer Simpson Peter Griffin oh
you know and if you've ever watched
Peppa Pig I mean I love Peppa Pig Daddy
Pig is just the worst representation of
fatherhood you've ever seen
um he's completely useless
um and that's funny
um so there's that there's
there is and I am
feminist to my very core unfortunately
there is an element of feminism that
doesn't want men to be involved
and they want the Primacy of the woman
to be kept as a parent
and they feel that men are moving into
what is a female space now if you look
at the evolutionary story and you look
at the science that's obviously
completely ludicrous
but it's a belief and I have had quite
I've had backlashes from fellow women
because of the work I do because I
should be studying mothers as a woman
um so there is that backlash governments
just don't want to invest in it you know
it's we've had the system we've had for
such a long time it doesn't matter I can
hit them over the head with my research
and my book till I'm blue in the face
and we have all been doing it recently
in the UK we've had a massive
consultation on paternity leave we all
trooped up to Parliament we all
presented everything which has been you
know it's highly highly convincing we
could show you the child outcomes we can
show you how much because ultimately
it's all about money we can show you how
much the government will ultimately save
but first of all they're not going to
save that money for like three decades
so this current government I'm not
interested because I will be well
retired by then
um and
they've just come out the end and
changed practically nothing
there was a real reluctance
to do it you know um even though we've
got perfect examples from northern
Europe where it works very very well
yeah it's it's a shame it's a shame I've
been having a lot of conversations I had
a lot of conversations about dating for
a long time and now I'm having a lot
about the role of men and masculinity
and what it means to be a man and so on
and so forth and um yeah it's
unfortunate that
any gains for men are seen as a a loss
for women you know there's a zero
Summoners to a lot of the conversations
and um yeah what else what what if
people said you're this uh
self-confessed feminist with her Bona
fides out front uh writing a book about
men and dads and saying that we need to
give them more budget and more attention
and more Care and More sympathy and more
resources what's the pushback been like
the pushback is
the pushback is I quite often get the
response
quite an angry response so I I every now
and then I get called in to do radio
phone ends and quite often I will get
somebody on the phone saying to me these
men you know haven't given birth they
haven't gone through the pain of it they
particularly if you're talking about
postnatal depression actually they
should all just pull themselves together
so that's a classic
um that there are limited resources and
all those resources should go to women
um and I can kind of see that argument
here with the NHS but what really gets
me is the lack of empathy because
empathy doesn't cost anything
it's Limitless but we have to pay the
Zero Sum game with empathy as well so if
we give any empathy to men then women
get less No actually that's not what
happens we're just empathizing with both
of them why is it that it's seen as a
loss that you're supporting a man you
can actually support both it's amazing
that you can't so you very much get that
attitude that you take you give to one
you're taking away from the other
um and
I find that stuff I find it astonishing
I find and you know when people say
particularly they pull themselves
together think to me I said you know I
do say something would you ever say that
to a woman who is struggling
so why do you think it's okay to say to
a man
you know
um but it's it's it's very ingrained I
think it's I think they feel threatened
um I think they feel threatened by what
it means about their identity and it
doesn't mean anything about their
identity but I think they think it does
it means we're taking some sort of
Primacy away from them I think maybe
I had a conversation I've had a few
conversations but uh Dr John Barry from
the center for male psychology gonna be
thinking about something so I'm going to
read you a little excerpt from one of my
newsletters recently a common question
is why don't men just do better surely
they can try harder in school employment
and health Chop Chop man hurry up and
stop being so useless well no other
group is told that when they suffer with
poor performance or accolades in the
real world that they should just pull
themselves up by their bootstraps we
don't tell any other group to talk about
their problems instead instead we spend
billions in taxpayer money and private
charity to set up committees departments
campaigns and funds to solve the problem
in simple terms if a woman has a problem
we ask what can we do to fix Society if
a man has a problem we ask what can men
do to fix themselves and I think that
this sort of imbalance specifically in
certain areas this isn't everywhere and
there are still areas in which the
imbalance runs in the other direction
but especially around parenting you know
there is this
empathy gap for sure oh yeah yeah Dr
John Barry calls it gamma bias I think
is his technical team for it and um yeah
it it sucks you could have a guy going
through postnatal depression being told
you you didn't go through the pain of
childbirth yeah I wasn't sure that I was
going to be a good dad and and you now
you're telling me that I'm I'm not being
sufficient and he is also you know I can
remember one of the
one of the guys who I work with who was
possibly one of the worst cases of
postnatal expression I saw and he was he
his wife the Trump the birth was
traumatic
he was left standing in a room on his
own for six hours with the newborn baby
he's been shoved in the Rain the wife
had been taken off somewhere nobody told
him anything he didn't they didn't give
him anything to feed the baby was
screaming he didn't know what he was
doing so first of all he thinks his
wife's dying nobody tells him whether
she's dying and he's left with this baby
then they get discharged from hospital
and because he only gets two weeks
paternity leave
that she's in hospital for 10 days so
he's actually home with the baby and the
wife who's still very ill for three days
then he has to go back to work leave her
on his own so he's like oh my God
feeling horribly guilty terribly
stressed how's she going to be on her
own gets home at night tries to do
everything stays up all night with the
baby then goes back to work then because
you know now I have to earn more money
because I was a child then takes a
promotion
um to a new job so we've got the
pressure of trying to impress the new
job learn the new job still got a sick
baby sick mom at home with baby and
surprise surprise
he gets postnatal depression of course
he does he's got all these different
conflicting you know with men are told
now you have to be the Hands-On father
and you have to be the perfect father
and you have to be really good at this
and you've got all these celebrity
fathers with their purposes and it's all
amazing and but you're also still told
no but you still have to be the
breadwinner and you have to be the Rock
and you're not allowed to have any
emotions about this and you're not
allowed to have any fears because this
is about Mom
and so that is a massive pressure cooker
of stress and if you and you know then
we add on top of that maybe you know you
might have had a history of depression
before or you might find it it's true or
let's say your partner's depressed if
your partner is depressed you are much
more like yourself to get postnatal
depression so it's just this massive
horrible mixture
that is gonna blow
what would you do
if you were able to prescribe some
cultural structural personal
psychological interventions or
suggestions for people either as a a
group or individually what do you wish
that more people or governments were
doing
I wish fundamentally
that everybody knew this about men I
wish they knew the science I wish they
knew the story of fatherhood I wish they
understood how important fathers were I
wish they understood what happened to a
man I wish they understood
how many different things there are to
balance and how difficult it is to be
told you have to be this but you also
have to be this
and you just have to slot into it okay
just so just do it
I wish that they knew that story and I
wish there were more groups I wish when
when parents did antenatal training that
there was more time spent just with men
helping them and seeing them actually
that they need as much support as mom
does but just in a different way
okay they just need a different sort of
sport and they need a different because
they are fundamentally going through as
much as I said before as much of an
emotional physiological changes moments
it's just hidden
that's all it's just not as obvious and
so I just wish we could share all this
information I wish that you know when
people learned about what happens to mum
they learn about what happens to Dad
and it's just seen as an equal journey
and what's what's really sad is actually
for a lot of couples it is an equal
journey and actually mums find this
really hard when they go into hospital
and Dad's shoved in a corner
or does not ask what he wants to do or
not asked to hold the baby or any of
these things or when the health visit
comes around after birth you know and
then she'll spend the whole time going
how are you Mum and we'll never ever at
any point say how are you dad
how are you doing is there anything
you're all concerned about would you
like to talk about it
you know because he's just the guy in
the corner you know making the tea
um so
I just wish people understood that
fathers are true co-parents and the true
co-parents for a very important reason
and if they weren't important they
wouldn't be here we just wouldn't have
them we'd be like you know our chimp
cousins
it's like what are you working on next
what's what's talk to me about what's
fascinating you now
I'm in the field of fatherhood actually
is
it's partly so
um
fathers of of kids with special needs
because
mums themselves with kids with special
needs certainly struggle for support and
recognition but for fathers there's
again even less recognition and also
this role of
trying to build resilience and trying to
scaffold your child's entry into World
beyond the family that is a whole bigger
job when you have a child with special
needs
um I have a daughter who's recently been
diagnosed with autism
and a big thing for us is okay how do we
prepare her to survive in the world
a world which isn't really adapted to
her needs and particularly my husband
particularly going forward into
relationships and things like that
that's something that's a real Focus for
him how can we give her the ability to
detect risk how can we give her the
ability to to deal with Challenge and to
deal with the social complexities which
is an autistic person it's really hard
so that's a real key thing for me now
it's a very unresearched area
and so I'd really like to you know start
looking at fathers who are in that
position I think
had the perfect mother for it though not
the perfect mother to be able to go out
and do the first-hand research and be
able to come up with the strategies Dr
animation ladies and gentlemen and I
absolutely love your work I think this
is very very very important uh and it's
fascinating and any friend of Robbins is
a friend of mine as well where should
people go if they want to keep up to
date with your stuff on the internet you
can follow me on Twitter so I'm Dr
animation on Twitter and you can follow
or you can go to my website which is
animation.com and it's all on there
oh yeah and I appreciate you thank you
thank you if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe